Well,
I mean,
I think writers,
no matter where you,
how many places you might settle in
life,
you're always only from one place.
And for me that's,
you know,
working class,
outer borough,
uh,
immigrant.
Um,
I grew up in a housing project so I,
you know,
that tends to be home for me when it,
when something sort of piques my
interest and makes me want to write,
I always tend to be gravitating back
towards that no matter what.
Um,
and I don't really challenge it anymore,
just go at it.
I don't really like,
you know,
I'm not going to write it about the
Spanish armada just to show people I'm
versatile.
I mean,
you know,
if,
if that's where something's telling me
to go,
I just go and I do the best job I can
and hopefully every timeout I'm writing
a little more nuanced and about the
different facet of life.
But,
you know,
a place is just a place,
it's what you're,
it's all about the human nature.
The only thing anybody ever writes about
his trouble,
you know,
and you can find plenty of trouble.
But by the same token,
look,
if,
if I grew up in the Midwest,
I,
I'd probably be writing about farms and,
you know,
and,
and midwestern life.
I was a southerner,
you know,
I'd,
I'd be trying to write like some tea,
you know,
third rate,
William Faulkner.
If I was from the desert,
I'd write like Cormac McCarthy,
you know,
you,
you go back,
you hear it calling to your whole life
no matter where you,
you are.